-Thank you very much.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys, it was just
another crazy week
and tonight President Trump
did his first
on-camera interview
since he got COVID.
Let's see who he decided
to talk to.
-We have just learned
this morning
that President Trump
is set to appear
in his first on-camera
interview tonight
and will apparently get
a medical evaluation,
not by the White House
physician,
but by a doctor on Fox News,
[ Laughter ]
according to the cable network.
-That's right, Trump got
a remote medical evaluation.
It's like a Zoom physical.
[ Laughter ]
It was a tough choice
for TV viewers --
Yankee playoff game,
NBA finals,
or hearing about
a 74-year-old man's body.
[ Laughter ].
"Can we catch all three?"
No, you can't.
A medical exam on TV?
I feel like Trump's
one step away
from taking a COVID test
on "Maury."
[ Laughter ]
"You do not have the virus!"
Aah!
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
I'm sure the guy who evaluated
Trump is qualified.
I mean, to be a Fox News doctor,
you have to go
to medical school in Queens
for a whole three hours.
[ Laughter ]
It was really
bizarre television,
especially when Trump
told the doctor --
[ As Trump ]
Might as well check
my prostate while I'm here.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, just --
-Oof.
At least, Trump seemed like
he was in a playful mood
during the exam.
When the doctor said
he would need a sample
of his blood, urine, and stool,
Trump gave him his underwear.
[ Audience oohs ]
-Ew!
- [ As Trump ]
Come on, it's a classic!
It's a classic!
[ Laughter ]
I've never really seen him
laugh, Trump, right?
What does he laugh like?
Like --
[ Silent ]
[ Laughter ]
Like a silent laugh?
-A Muppet, yeah.
-Yeah, he's like a Muppet,
like --
[ Laughter ]
-Maybe like a robot, like
"Ah-ah-ah-ah-ah-ah."
[ Laughter ]
-Or maybe he's like, you know,
some people laugh
like Ernie, too. Like --
[ Snickering ]
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah.
Yeah, that's a good one, yeah.
-[ Snickering ]
Yeah, that's a good one.
[ Laughter ]
Actually, I was impressed
with the doctor.
He remembered every single word
Trump told him to say.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Trump was given
a virtual medical exam on TV.
I guess that explains
this promo I saw.
[ Suspenseful theme plays ]
That's why you should watch...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah, the last few days,
Trump has been all
over Fox News.
Last night, he called in
to Sean Hannity.
At this point, even regular
Fox News viewers are like,
"Ugh.
This guy, again?"
[ Laughter ]
By now, anytime
Trump calls Fox News,
it comes up as potential spam.
[ Laughter ]
During the interview,
Trump didn't sound too good.
Take a listen to this.
[ Clears throat ]
-Yeah.
-Yeah --
[ Clears throats ]
[ Clears throat ]
-Wow!
-[ Murmuring ]
-That's great. The president
of the United States
is slowly turning
into the Mucinex monster.
[ Laughter ]
A second later,
Trump was like --
[ As Trump ]
[ Coughing ]
Sorry, hair ball.
[ Laughter ]
Hannity then tried asking Trump
if he'd been tested for COVID
and Trump wouldn't
give a clear answer.
Listen to this.
-Have you been
tested recently?
-Or sooner, maybe.
I know I'm whether
I'm great shape or not.
-Did you test negative?
[ Laughter ]
-Have you had a test
since your diagnosis a week ago?
[ Laughter ]
-So...the answer is no.
His doctor will only examine him
on TV from 200 miles away.
I think it's safe to say
that he's still positive.
[ Laughter ]
It's like being asked,
"How'd your history test go?"
And you go, "Yes."
[ Laughter ]
Later in the interview,
Hannity asked Trump
what he thought would happen
under Biden's environmental plan
and he had a pretty
interesting response.
[ Laughter ]
-"Rebuild them with tiny,
little windows
so you cannot see light."
[ Laughter ]
Is he attacking the Democrats
or writing a haiku?
[ Laughter ]
I'm worried about Trump.
But later, he was like --
[ As Trump ]
To the window,
[ Laughter ]
to the wall,
'till the sweat drop down my
[ Coughing ]
[ Laughter ]
Hair balls.
It didn't stop there.
Trump then talked
about California's
water situation.
Listen to this.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter intensifies ]
-No! No!
[ Applause ]
No!
[ Laughter ]
No. No, man.
-I swear, it's real.
-Y'all did that.
-No, it's real.
No, that is his exact --
-This is the new "Do Not Read."
Y'all did that.
-I swear.
-There's no way!
[ Laughter ]
-Tiny windows, tiny fish.
He sounds like
those YouTube videos of kids
after they get
their wisdom teeth out.
[ Laughter ]
Then, today, Trump called in
to Rush Limbaugh's radio show
for two hours.
-Agh!
-And, at one point,
he dropped an F-bomb
while talking about Iran.
Listen to this.
-And Iran knows that and they've
been put on notice --
if you [bleep] around with us,
if you do something bad to us,
we are going to do things to you
that have never
been done before.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. When Mike Pence
heard Trump curse,
he took two flies
and stuck them in his ears.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Pence ]
Not today, Satan!
[ Laughter ]
Well, Trump says he's
feeling better
and doctors are crediting
his recovery
to some advanced treatments,
including a steroid.
But I don't know if it's
the best choice for Trump.
Take a look at this ad
I saw the other night.
-Reclaim the day with...
Dexamethasone
has been used to treat
moderate to severe cases
of COVID-19.
While effective, dexamethasone
isn't for everyone.
You shouldn't take
dexamethasone if you...
[ Laughter ]
Side effects may include...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey, this is going viral --
a woman shared a picture
of a frozen tuna steak
that looks like President Trump.
Take a look at this.
See if you can see the --
[ Audience oohs ]
[ Laughter ]
Trump saw that and was like --
[ As Trump ]
Now, that's the tan
I'm looking for.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, I saw that
a pet owner wanted
to keep her dogs in the yard,
but she also wanted them
to see her come home,
so she came up
with this solution.
[ Laughter ]
-Hi!
Hi.
-[ Whining ]
[ Laughter ]
-That's what happens
when you're trapped
in your house
for seven months.
"I'm gonna go make some
dog holes in the fence."
[ Laughter ]
Honey, any headway
with the job search?
"No, but I made a couple of --
couple dog holes in the --"
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, these days,
it can feel like
there's a lot going wrong
with the world
and sometimes you just wish
you could make it right.
Well, luckily, we're able to do
that here at "The Tonight Show."
It's time
for "This Week Made Right."
Check it out.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-Shockingly, President Trump
has left Walter Reed hospital
to ride around in his SU--
Oh, wait a second.
-Aaaaah!
[ Laughter ]
Okay, yep, that's probably
for the best.
-Get in there!
-Aaah!
-That's right, after a heated
presidential debate last week,
the VP candidates have agreed
to sit in silence
and smile at one another.
Let's take a look.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Shocker for the Patriots
this week.
Cam Newton is out with COVID.
He could be done for the season.
-Oh, wait a second, Al.
Not so fast.
-Well, look at that.
It's Cam Newton.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Is a great insult...
[ Fly buzzing ]
...to the men and women
who serve in law enforcement
and I want everyone to know,
who puts on the uniform.
[ Laughter ]